uncomfortable reshoots accusations of
dishonesty disagreements about directors
these are just some of the reasons these
actors were miserable while shooting a
thor movie keep watching to learn
everything you need to know about the
who and why the most recent thor movies
are known for being lighter and more fun
than many other mcu films the latest
entry thor love and thunder is no
exception from its guardians of the
galaxy hijinks to the hilarious giant
screaming
goats and giant coats look at those they
are wonderful reviewers have praised
this lighthearted take colliders perry
nemeroff posted about the film loads of
laughs my face legit hurts menace of
christian bale's gore is chilling but
most of all loved that it's a film
brimming with good vibes and heart but
that doesn't mean the thor movies have
always been fun to make for all the
actors involved while these films look
like they must have been a blast to
create the intense level of pressure
involved along with issues behind the
scenes means that it wasn't all fun for
everyone on set take for example
christopher eccleston you may know him
best for playing the ninth doctor with
the catchphrase
he famously did not think his experience
on doctor who was fantastic though he
also didn't like being malikith the
accursed the ruler of the dark elves and
thor the dark world for his thor woes
the actor blames a bit of dishonesty
during negotiations he told metro that
he was led to believe there would only
be a little makeup he said what they
didn't say was that it'd be seven hours
of it which was very dishonest of them
that was a miserable experience and a
dreadful performance metro isn't the
only media outlet he complained to he
explained to the guardian how horrible
his experiences were on both gi joe the
rise of cobra in which he played destro
and thor the dark world saying both
roles were regrettable however eccleston
has also made clear that he has no beef
with the cast and crew of the dark world
singling out director alan taylor and
star chris hemsworth for praise he told
metro i loved working with allen he's a
great director and hemsworth was
fantastic a generous actor who really
had his feet on the ground considering
he's appeared in multiple mcu films you
might think idris elba who plays the
asgardian heimdall the former guardian
of the bifrost bridge had a great time
yet like eccleston he said some harsh
things about thor the dark world
specifically elba told the telegraph in
2014 that right after he finished
playing activist nelson mandela in
mandela long walk to freedom he was
contractually obligated to return to the
2013 thor sequel for reshoots this
included an uncomfortable scene in which
he was falling from a spaceship elba
explained i was like this is torture man
i don't want to do this 24 hours ago i
was mandela then there i was in this
stupid harness with this wig and the
sword and these contact lenses it ripped
my heart out even so elba has also
praised taylor and his vision for the
dark world in a flicks and the city
interview and given his continued
presence in the mcu after that it seems
like his issues with the thor reshoots
might have been more situational rather
than a deeper resentment in fact it's
clear the actor wants more work in the
marvel universe not less in 2017 he told
entertainment weekly i like what i have
but i also wish that i had a bigger
character in the marvel universe
there is always hope
one more actor who wasn't thrilled with
the dark world was natalie portman who
became disenchanted with the thor
franchise and reportedly declined to
show up for reshoots for the sequel she
didn't appear in any more marvel films
setting aside a cameo that reused dark
world footage in avengers end game until
love and thunder she also made her beef
public in 2011 the hollywood reporter
reported that portman was deeply unhappy
that her choice for the sequel's
director patty jenkins who would go on
to direct wonder woman was ousted by
marvel following creative differences
the publication said that portman had
already been on the fence about
returning to the franchise because she
wanted to spend time with her family
while vulture noted that she gained a
renewed excitement about the role when
jenkins was hired once jenkins was gone
this presumably changed us reports that
when she said filming conflicts
prevented her from returning for
reshoots hemsworth's real-life wife elsa
pataki filled in for her in an interview
with the wall street journal in 2016
portman said i don't know if one day
they'll ask for an avenger 7 or whatever
i have no idea but as far as i know i'm
done it was a great thing to be a part
of but she obviously had enough fond
memories to finally come back to the
role in love and thunder once jane was
finally given a bigger role according to
cnn it reportedly only took one meeting
for taika ytt to convince her to sign up
again
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]